I'm ready to see my old [ __ ] let's see
it
I've always liked liked old people like
I've just thought old men are cool
looking so I'm hoping like I'm a cool
looking old man but I can also see
myself being like a creepy looking old
man take care of myself
I workout I ride my bike a lot it smokes
cigarettes daily sometimes it can be
anywhere from like 5 to 15 it really
just depends on the mood I'm in and how
much I got going on I know my family and
we pretty much look the same I don't
think I'm gonna age much I'm ascared I'm
a little worried I'm a little nervous
my face is slimmer I think too which is
interesting okay
all right not that different really the
bags under my eyes have gotten a little
bigger my face is like sagging a little
more yeah if the face seems to be
thinning out a little bit from two in
ten years from now and I'm starting to
look a little old
no no it's mostly under the eyes like
that it's really increasing and I'm
getting more like crow's feet kind of
things over here okay now I'm starting
to see like some sort of more sort of
lines here in the cheeks I think I am in
the grave already actually I look dead I
look old but I look healthy hopefully a
healthy old guy I'm seeing a lot more
like lines in my face here the eyes like
around the eyes look a little just just
aged this is probably from looking at
computers all in my life looking at a
lot of screens those eyes have seen
things yeah I mean it's just weird it's
so weird to see this photo and just like
almost like see yourself as a
grandfather or like a great grandfather
it's wild man I mean definitely makes me
appreciate the now
seventy-five is a smoker you're looking
like you're you're like picking out the
casket to be honest like it's it's
pretty bad yeah man this is a wake-up
call for sure we have one time to do
this life we have one body we have to
take care of ourselves I look at this
photo I go like that guy doesn't look
like he feels good when you're young you
feel like you're invincible but being
pushed in the face of this image of
myself way down the road in my life
reminds me like everything I do today is
gonna have an effect on me later and I
need to be [ __ ] careful with what I
put in my body how I treat my body
because I want to live to a ripe old age
I mean I need to find a man now because
if I'm looking around for a man when
looking like this it ain't gonna happen